you
[Music]
good afternoon president-elect biden and
i just met with a bipartisan group of
democratic and republican governors
we talked about what we need to do to
make free testing available for everyone
to make a free vaccine available for
everyone and to get
this pandemic under control governors
are elected by their states to take
action in moments of crisis
they're the ones who go to the places
and talk to the people
who are hardest hit and during this
pandemic
they have been called on to make very
difficult decisions
about the health and safety of the
people they represent
about opening schools and about opening
our economy
responsibly i have served in both state
and local government
so i understand the critical role our
governors play
and they will have partners in the white
house starting on january 20th
because as governor herbert said in our
meeting when the states are successful
the country is successful so our message
to our governors
and to all of our nation's state and
local leaders is simple
president-elect biden and i will make
sure you have the resources and support
you need
to save lives and help get our economy
back on track
and we will also make sure that our
federal state local and tribal
authorities
are working closely together so we can
tackle these challenges as effectively
as possible because when it comes to
this pandemic
and the economic recovery we are not
democrats
or republicans we are americans and we
will be there
for one another that's the kind of
leadership the american people need
and deserve and it's the kind of
leadership president-elect biden and i
will provide
and it is now my great honor to
introduce president-elect
joe biden
[Music]
hello folks good afternoon thanks for
your patience
the vice and i just pointed out
have uh just concluded a video
conference
with the executive leadership at the
national governor's conference
they included governor cuomo new york
governor hutchinson
governor hogan governor whitmer governor
ivey governor
polis governor baker governor
lujan grisham governor herbert and
governor carney
and it was really a worthwhile
undertaking you know uh they've had to
make some really tough calls during this
unprecedented crisis
and we're incredibly grateful for
everything they've done and
keep doing to try to keep their
communities safe
unfortunately because of the lack of
a discernment as they say uh which is
that's a fancy word these days but until
the
head of the gsa says that we in fact our
team this transition
team our team the senator and i
have in fact are the likely winners
until she does that
we don't have access to all the
information that we need to get from all
the various agencies
we're not able to deal with everything
from testing the guidance to the
all-important issue of vaccine
distribution and even more importantly
vaccination plan to actually get
vaccinations
we haven't been able to get into
operation warp speed
but we will take what we've learned
today and build it into our planning
the country is still in a crisis
cover 19. and there are empty chairs and
dining room tables
just fulfilled just days and weeks ago
with loved ones family friends who
laughed and talked together
to those families and friends that are
left behind jill and i send our
our love and our prayers we know like
many of you do how tough it is to
find purpose in the memory of a loved
one you've just lost
it'll take time but you'll find it
you'll find it
and we'll and you'll find your purpose
as we're going to find our purpose
for our nation as a nation now i promise
you that
and i promise you that we'll work
together there's a there's a great
meeting we had today
all the governors no matter their
political party
whether they're from wherever part of
the country they represent it
no matter their political philosophy
shared a strong
and abiding sense of a common purpose
there was a real desire
for a real partnership between the
states and the federal government
each of the governors emphasized that we
might be democrats
republicans but we're all americans
first
they congratulated us heartily for the
the
our win what really pleased me was the
most was that governors made clear that
beating covet 19 is going to require
all of us working together as one
country
kamal and i agree we are we were deeply
impressed with how much consensus there
was
how to move forward among the governors
what we need to do now
is how we need to do it how are we going
to do it
in what coordinated way can it be done
we discussed a number of critical ways
we can work together
and unify around a national approach to
controlling covet 19.
first delivering economic relief to the
city states and tribal communities
the lost revenue from covet and the cost
of cover recovery is devastating to
state and local budgets as governors
as all of them indicated we've got to
come together
the federal government has to deliver
this release
sooner rather than later and with
flexibility for the states to meet their
needs
this includes helping businesses schools
working families
from unemployment benefits to early
education continued access to affordable
health care
all of that's needed during this
pandemic states and communities
shouldn't have to lay off teachers
cops firefighters cut vital services for
families and businesses
the second thing there was uniform
agreement on delivering a safe
and equitable and free vaccine
the governor's all acknowledged that
there'll be a massive undertaking
one of the greatest operational
challenges we will have faced as a
nation
one statistic that was raised by the
governors
it took eight months to provide
100 million covet tests eight months
to provide covertest just imagine how
much more difficult will be they pointed
out
if we don't find a more efficient and
effective way
to provide 330 million vaccinations
put in perspective they made the point
we can't wait
that's what the governors are raising in
the media we discussed the challenges
that lie ahead
in distributing and administering the
vaccine
the governor's talked about how getting
doses of vaccine distributed
is just one step we have to actually get
vaccinations into the arms of 330
million americans that takes enormous
resources
people product we discuss the difficulty
of that task it's going to take time
it's going to take coordination it's
going to take the federal government and
state governments working
hand in glove working together governors
and
the governors all emphasized we need to
be clear with the american people
about what to expect no false
expectations let them know what we
anticipate
they all acknowledge that this is going
to take a massive public education
campaign
and we also need to reach traditionally
underserved communities
that are being hardest hit by the
pandemic black brown latino latin
american community native american
communities
small towns rural communities they
talked about that in some detail
thirdly we discussed the need to help
states with title 32
funding for the national guard that's a
fancy way
governor discussed the need for funding
when waiving certain fema fees
the fact is that this is a national
emergency that's what fema is supposed
to deal with
our view is that should be done when it
comes to deploying the national guard or
covert or real relief
that should be paid for you know that's
something kamalai will be very focused
on
and fourthly we discussed the
implementation
of a national mass mandate ten governors
democrat and republican have imposed
masking requirements
and recognized the need for universal
masking north south east and west
is not a political statement it's a
patriotic duty
and fifth we discussed making testing
more available and accessible
anyone who wants a test should be able
to get one period
and finally while we focused on the
immediate needs to control the virus
the governor's also raised and talked
about how much we have to build back
better especially on
infrastructure and education and so much
more
this was not a one-off meeting i
committed we committed
we agreed that we'll continue to work
and meet with the governors
on a regular basis continue to seek
their input
and that our covet teams will follow up
and coordinate
on the issues coming out of that call
because some of them have very
competent people on their covet teams in
their states
the bottom line we can do this
there's nothing beyond our capacity but
we have to come together as a country
what this meeting along with others
we've had reinforces in my view
is the unity the country is looking for
they're looking for
us to come together and deal
with problems most of which have no
ideological basis
for disagreement that's what we have to
do
that's what the governors talked about
it really was pleasing to hear them
i want to thank you all and may god
bless you all those who lost someone
you're in our prayers
may god protect our troops i'm happy to
take a few questions
and my boss is going to tell me who that
is
uh thank you mr president-elect
i know you mentioned the economic impact
and talked a bit about the relief
package you wanted
but i was wondering if we could talk
about things that you'll be able to do
just as president
or what will sort of govern your
decision uh in terms of the economy
so i was wondering if i could ask what
kind of framework you're thinking about
as you decide about a treasury secretary
going forward uh whether you would
consider
you had said during the debates that you
wanted to punish china over the way that
they've been acting
whether that could include economic
sanctions or tariffs towards china
and finally do you think a strong dollar
helps or hurts
the us as we're grappling with historic
unemployment
well look let me try to take them one at
a time you'll soon hear my choice for
treasury i made that decision we've made
that decision
and you'll hear that either just before
just after thanksgiving
number one and you'll find it is someone
who
i think is uh will be accepted by all
elements of the democratic party
progressive to the moderate
coalitions secondly
it's not so much about punishing china
it's about making sure china understands
they got to play by the rules
it's a simple proposition and so that's
one of the reasons why we're going to
rejoin the world health organization
we're going to rejoin
on day one as well and it needs reform i
acknowledge
and rejoin the paris climate accord
and we have to make sure that the rest
of the world
and we get together and make sure there
are certain bright lines chinese
understand
we have to not only deal with this
pandemic but a plan for the next one
the idea that viruses are going to go
away is just not rational
we're going to re we're going to
recalibrate and set up the
the institute we the institutional
structures we had
in our administration of obama biden and
build on it
and what was your third question it's
about the dollar sir whether you think a
strong dollar
uh will help or hurt with unemployment
or
generally just how you'd like the
federal reserve to sort of approach the
well quite frankly the way the federal
reserve has been approaching uh
uh the uh uh
dealing with dollar hazard i think has
been in a positive direction
our interest rates are as low as they
have been in modern history
uh and i think that is a positive thing
it lends credence to the possibility of
us being able to expend the money
and deficit spend in order to be able to
generate economic growth right off the
bat
and so i think it's been positive so far
thank you
thank you mr president-elect you have
said that if this transition doesn't get
going especially coordination on vaccine
distribution
that lives will be lost how many lives
do you think
are at risk here if this transition
remains stalled well look we've
you you've heard the projections the
projections are that
if nothing fundamentally changes between
now and uh
beginning of february we're likely to
lose up to 400 total of 400 thousand
lives another 150 000 lives
and so it's real whether it's that it
gets to 360 whatever it is it's real
and there is no excuse not to
share the data and let us begin to plan
because on day one it's going to take us
time if we don't have access to all this
data
it's going to put us behind the eight
ball by a matter of a month or more
and that's lives how many would be lost
as a consequence of that i can't tell
you
but the purpose here is to get we talked
a lot about what the governor is about
what the immediate needs are i'm going
to we're going to impose the we're going
to enforce the
excuse me employ the defense uh
reconstruct the act
to be able to go out there and dictate
companies build and do following things
we need much more testing we need much
more masking we mean that's more we need
clothes
i asked them east to go and ask the
national governor association through
the governor
cuomo and the ones on the line to let us
know what their shortages are what they
anticipate
because we're going to move on day one
that should be moved on
now now but if it waits
it takes a long time to get this thing
going and when you take a step back and
you look at the way the president is
handling this his refusal to concede
what do you think is really going on
here in your view
mr president-elect what do you think the
president is doing what are
americans witnessing here
let me choose my words oh here uh i
think they're witnessing incredible
irresponsibility
incredibly damaging messages being sent
to the rest of the world about how
democracy functions
and i think it is uh um
well i don't know his motive but i i
just think it's totally irresponsible
are you concerned you may succeed that
people may question the legitimacy of
your administration
no i'm not concerned the vast majority
of the american people they've already
all the polling data has indicated
although the republicans who
worry about it it's higher but the over
78 percent of the american people
believe it's
without question it's legitimate um
and i just think it's uh and i think
most of the
republicans i've spoken to including the
governors think this
is debilitating it's not a it sends a
horrible message about who we are as a
country
thank you mr president-elect thank you
president vice president-elect harris
appreciate it
nice to see you as well yes appreciate
it
um you have said that lives could be
lost if you don't start getting
briefings from the trump administration
and now here we are more than 250 000
lives
could be lost given that how do you
justify
not taking legal action to get the
briefings that you say
are critical that you say you need it
would take a lot of time
take it would take time it's not going
to speed it up considerably in my view
and in the meantime i i am
hopeful that i'm going to be able to get
cooperation from our republican
colleagues in the senate in the house as
well as
on the governors to build a consensus of
how we proceed when we do
but why not use every tool in your
toolbox to get the information that
you say you need to do your job and to
do it effectively on day one
i'm making a judgment based on many
years of experience and how to get
things done with the opposition
my judgment is my judgment is that
it is we'll get further along
by actually um
working with our republican colleagues
now
and uh because the time in which we
would win
would not materially change necessarily
but it's still an open question it's an
open question it could change
so you haven't ruled it out you haven't
ruled out legal action against the trump
administration against the gsa
we haven't ruled it out okay and given
the death toll now more than 250 000
americans who have now lost their lives
you have said that
you would support a nationwide shutdown
if scientists recommended it
no you've spoken to scientists here keep
everybody asked that question
every single time i stand here it was a
hypothetical question
the answer was i would follow the
science i am not going to shut down the
economy
period i'm going to shut down the virus
that's what i'm going to shut down so
that's why
again no national shutdown
no national shutdown because
every region every area every community
is can be different and so there's no
circumstance which i can see
would require a total national shutdown
i think that would be counterproductive
but
there are constraints in which
the degree to which businesses can be
open for example
it's one thing to say that you can have
uh
in a state that is there where their
infection rate is not as high you can
have a
gymnasium open it's another thing to say
can only be open four hours a day with x
number of people
the church i'd go to my catholic church
they don't allow more than 40
of the people are to come into the
church
those are rational decisions it's not
shutting down everything it's
calibrating based on what the what the
threat is
thank you mr president
thank you mr vice president elect
thank you mr president-elect and vice
president elect harris
um a question for you first which is
what do you make of the fact that the
president is
having these calls with michigan county
officials
amid his bid to overturn the election
he's going to be having also
michigan republican legislators at the
white house tomorrow anything that he's
doing
making you rethink your strategy i know
you say that you don't want to have
legal action right now
and what do you say to americans
especially immigrant americans who came
to the united states
looking for political stability and
seeing all the things that the president
is doing
hang on i'm on my way that's what i say
to them
not a joke and what the president's
doing now is uh
is really um
it's going to uh
be another incident where he will go
down in history
as being one of the most irresponsible
presidents in american history
it's it's just out of the
not even within the norm at all there's
questions whether it's even legal
but uh it's going to be interesting who
shows up
uh in this call to meet with the
leadership
and uh but um this is going to
we we've won michigan it's going to be
certified we're going to end up
making clear that they are
remain clear that we want and uh
but it just uh i i just
it's hard to fathom how this man thinks
it's hard to fathom
i i'm confident he knows he hasn't won
and is not going to be able to win and
we're going to be sworn into january
20th
and i just uh you know but
far for me to question his motive it's
just it's just outrageous what he's
doing
but that's as he as he ups the things
that he's doing calling officials is it
making you rethink your strategy at all
is there anything that he would be doing
that would make you say okay we really
have to go to court now
or are you still watching what he's
doing and saying we can still
kind of wait and see what happens
i i'm not going to rule anything out or
anything in
but at the moment the strategy is not
it's not changing
and if i could ask a question to the
vice president-elect with that sure
um vice president-elect harris you
talked about your state
um your state experience my question is
is there anything that you heard from
governors today
that made you specifically concerned
about vulnerable populations
especially as i talked to americans who
say i don't have the privilege to work
from home i don't have the privilege
to social distance if i'm living in a
house with multi generations are
you did you hear anything um that
concerns you specifically
and what can we do for them as a country
well as the president-elect
shared with with everyone we heard a lot
from the governors including that
um including the concern that uh
african-americans latinos native
americans people who live in rural
communities
uh people who as as groups of people
have historically been
um under resourced and underserved and
so there was consensus among the
the governor's bipartisan consensus that
our federal strategy
should reflect those concerns in a way
that we support the states with the
resources they'll need
to get to the folks who have been often
overlooked or ignored
and the president-elect i think has made
it very clear that it's one of our
highest priorities
to support that as you may know in the
senate i actually
led what we call the racial disparities
task force
and that approach is something that we
will be incorporating in our
administration
to ensure that all people have equal
access to resources but
also taking it into account equitable
distribution of resources based on need
thank you president-elect one important
thing to understand
is there is a and we've talked a lot
about this and we've talked about it i
talked about it when i was running
seeking the nomination as well
and that is that the idea of the
brown black
asian american native american
communities
are always the first ones hit the
hardest the last ones
who are brought back we're going to flip
that around
it's going to be really important to
determine priorities
based upon access to the information
that's available
access to everything from the vaccine
to other opportunities to
be able to deal with helping the country
part of the country and hurt the worst
you know three times as many
african-americans have died
than white americans died from
copenhagen
so there has to be a prioritization
that's what i'd like to know exactly
what this uh
what this administration has in mind in
terms of their operation warp speed and
how they plan it and that's what we
talked about with the governors today
they all mentioned the need to focus on
the communities have been left behind
particularly governor cuomo it's one
thing if for example
vaccines you distributed all the
walgreens of america
i'm not no criticism of walgreens but
you know there's a lot of those
facilities that aren't in rural
communities
and are not in poor communities
african-american latino communities
so we've got to make sure there's access
for them
thank you so much
[Music]
okay thank you